给大家介绍一个真的让我们人生发什么改变的方法
我说的是一定
过年了我看好多了会有问题说胡子哥
我真的想做出一些改变
能给这条路吗
我说这个做过早就给你们吃了
两年前就开始吃了
你做了吗
每天写点什么
有人说
我不知道写点啥呀就是我写什么呢
我说你想做出什么的改变
你想做什么
你就写什么
如果样做东西就写如何做东西
如果想赞钱你就写如何赚钱
可是我不会赚钱呀
不会就去写呀
多普通的道理啊怎么写呀
早就说
或者是找一些
就做出过成的人
但是你广停不停啊
做着听用什么
你是不在理解一样
写了做本身就是一个思考的过程
小完了把它发出来
有人提出不同的关键
有人说要这个实际情况是这个这个这个这样的
对吧
理论和实际就这样
理论听才是这么个道理
可是实际
是要有细节的
可能会有多各种各样的问题
细节道理该怎么处理
那你要去试操
试操的过程中会有反思了呀你就会有中节呀
每天写点什么的一个完视用的闭款是
学习理解思考
实验
长事犯错
然后中节的反思
对吧但是它不是一次就完成的
你可能之前就是学习理解
然后试操的反思在试操在反思
这是一个完整的闭款
是一个闭主
就是不一年我要干嘛我要做东西我要发财
可以没问题一年
每天抽这个方向
前进一步
那还能说我做不到
对吧
我这个人有个习惯是三天打鱼两天才访
没问题三天打鱼两天才访又如何呢
我给你出个三
一天打鱼六天才访行没用
每周共亿住
一家零点零一的四十八次访
你知道多少吗
每年你会计划百分之六十
这个了不起
要不得呀
可是我们很久没怎么办
不行
我我真是方法太简单了
我想学点那种高级的
对吧
我去报告班
我觉得我大事我学过
柯王某点我一下子就立了
各位这个级绣我是一点一点短点起来的
你花了一斤下来的
工厉的级绣下来
那个是到我去
泡漫一旦破了
你还是那个纯果
所以他有一点老火几万
又是一年了
对吧
日宝旅住没天写点什么
你的人生一定会发生改变的